let's talk about Donald Trump and rape
because it's Monday and seems like a
good topic we've been telling you about
the Jane Doe who filed three federal
complaints about Donald Trump against
Donald Trump for alleged child rape in
connection with a party that she
attended involving not only Donald Trump
but also Jeffrey Epstein and this
allegedly happened back in nineteen
ninety four the victim the alleged
victim was thirteen years old up at the
time and we have not learned that much
about the victim until now we now know
that the accuser is Katie Johnson the
most recent federal filing includes
three affidavits one from Katie Johnson
herself previously known to us as Jane
Doe plus two more
an eyewitness named Tiffany doe and also
a John Doe a classmate of Johnson's back
from 1994 now Johnson's story has been
the same this entire time throughout all
of these court proceedings she recalled
being approached by Tiffany who
allegedly worked for Jeffrey Epstein at
the time
Tiffany invited Katie Johnson who was
then an aspiring model to an event in
Epstein's home to get to know people and
maybe get a modeling job and throughout
the summer of 1994 the lawsuit alleges
that Johnson endured quote savage sexual
attacks by both Donald Trump and Jeffrey
Epstein I have video testimony I'm going
to play for you I want to warn you it is
disturbing you will notice that
Johnson's voice has been altered and her
face has been blurred notwithstanding
that the this is disturbing I am again
giving you the opportunity to skip past
this or to come back in about a minute
and a half let's listen to miss Johnson
here second time that I saw mr. Trump
was he and Tiffany came over to me and
said that Donald Trump had requested
that I perform oral sex on him
and I was basically tied to our bed
armor Fanny Harris and retirement is
there a certain ahead and her team
reclaim it and I tried to now try to say
something I was like yeah and he's just
shot shot [ __ ] you know this is it's
basically like he was just being really
really important and I started to get
scared and and he was basically like my
clothes off him and I was actually I
started I've thought for time just
turned on this animal I was like a
completely different
I'm completely different person I can do
anything about it
rip off my clothes and he started to
basically have sex with me and I was
screaming I never had sex before my
first time yeah appalling and dreadful
now of course Donald Trump has denied
Johnson's claims since April Trump
representatives have said that he and
Epstein barely even knew each other but
The Daily Beast reports that they were
actually regularly seen together during
the 1990s and as I told you last week or
the week before a federal judge in New
York has ordered a hearing in December
about this case this story Pat sort of
proves that the entire the media is out
to get Trump theory is total BS because
if corporate media wanted to take down
Trump they would be covering this story
and they would have been covering this
story for months instead yeah they
talked about the sexual assault
allegations this is very disturbing
video that is now out there and it's not
getting corporate media coverage clearly
media doesn't have it that much out for
Trump because they'd be talking about
this if they did and maybe they're not
covering it because it seems unlikely
but when you combine all the sexual
assault allegations the fact that in
court proceedings one of his ex-wife's
testified that yes indeed Trump did rape
her
yeah and that he would walk around
dressing rooms of Miss Teen USA s young
girls as young as 15 years old you put
that all together this isn't far-fetched
at all it's all the same story I mean
all of the different pieces that we've
heard all tell the exact same story and
if Donald Trump wins on November 8th on
December 16th the president-elect will
be the accused in a child rape trial
think about that for a second for a
second Gamefly is sort of like Netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one Xbox 360
ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fee
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at Gamefly offer.com /t dps the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included there's no
contracts and you can rent games through
the mobile app get the free 30-day trial
for the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s